[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ou lana et si nantes
pimprenelle et nicolas en l'air très
sage ce soir ils dorment peut-être déjà
ou alors ils sont sûrement très absorbé
par un travail important
j'ai bien peur qu'il me prépare une
force potes ou une belle surprise
mon gros nounours oh le petit ange
bon le seul gilles fonrouge patron comme
notre cher nounours est vraiment trop
confiants les bigoudis et le démer loire
il prône l tu crois qu'il va aimer ça
nos bourses aux proches voir le petit
homme au soir au mais je suis chez un
coiffeur ce soit prenez dans place
monsieur nous nous vita faute est à
votre client mon petit nicolas voilà
madame la patronne la bouche et vous
monsieur mur si le gars au là où je suis
du semnon on va bientôt soignées tu veux
être encore plus beau alors qu'est ce
que ce sera pour monsieur
une belle mise en pis une permanente à
froid une bonne coupe heureusement comme
papa ou le bon
vous n'êtes pas très bien coiffé vous
savez ans seulement alors vous automne
epinoux nous apporter dans une serviette
petit garçon coiffeur et voit la
patronne d'un prône elle ne bouge pas
d'un nom tel attache au tour de taz les
petites nuque la merci mon petit à
porter dont quelques morceaux de glace
pourquoi
[Musique]
et voilà les glaçons pour monsieur
nomura diablement vous rafraîchira peu
monsieur on va vous faire la coupe
rafraîchi entraîneur de mousse et en
même temps on va bouffer incomplet
manucure et pédicure
est ce que c'est le sport c'est pour
matin
ces chinois monsieur nono pour vous
faire de bauzon delaveau grosses pattes
thoune au monde où zoug en salle et vos
pieds c'est bien ce que je craignais
vous avez un anglais carnet c'est pas
quand vos un peu de courage monsieur
nous nous pauvres qu'on annonce un
carnet anosy garçons vous vous occupez
de la tête et moi des pieds et des mains
ouais mais bon et en avant les glaçons
la houle bon de fleurs là mais outils là
qu'une victime de tes patins et nous en
ce moment la houle va pas tourner de te
douillet et un petit coup de mme heloir
dans ces jolies bouclettes nouveaux
bleus
oui monsieur wauquiez là attention où
nous tue c'est fini un petit peu de
poudre
là ça fait ni de jo
ça fait quatre ans monsieur et n'oubliez
pas le service et c'est pas cher car on
vous a fait du bon travail aux scouts
bon non non ce bois pouvons-nous nous à
damas
oh
bon
[Musique]
c'est bien ce que je vous disais
nounours est trop confiant à te voilà
mon bon ami tu as été long regardez
comme je suis beau patron ou mode path
où nous allons route
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents et faites de beaux
rêves
à demain auto bord
[Musique]